[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestros periodistas soy
herminia Fernández por Andrés espinal
las vidas de las familias en Ucrania
serán más difíciles a medida que se
acerque el invierno las temperaturas
bajo cero y las fuertes Nevadas están a
solo unas semanas ya los ucranianos
están preparando para las horas
condiciones en medio de la escasez de
energía y gas estel bonetti Diego Ibarra
Sánchez nos cuentan más
Elena con la ayuda de su hijo misa se
afanan a limpiarlo sus escombros del
tejado para poder aislarlo con plásticos
antes de que llegue el frío su casa como
la mayoría de las casas residenciales de
su barrio ha sido destruida por los
bombardeos olen está preocupada por las
limitaciones del gas y los cortes de
electricidad en los próximos meses
va a ser muy duro el precio del gas es
muy caro y no sé cómo vamos a poder
pagarlo Así que estoy reutilizando los
muebles y ventanas para usarlos como
leña
Esta es la escuela donde estudiaba misas
recibe el impacto de una explosión y se
rompieron las ventanas el colegio arabió
en septiembre pero directora ha tenido
que mandar a los alumnos a estudiar
online porque las aulas no están
acondicionadas para el invierno
Estamos buscando fondos para reponer las
ventanas nuestros alumnos estudian
online porque no podemos dar clases así
necesitamos reparar la escuela para que
podamos regresar a las aulas
la reconstrucción es uno de los
principales desafíos de Cara a este
invierno al que se enfrentan miles de
familias ucranianas que viven en hogares
shemales condiciones para soportar Las
bajas temperaturas
esto es todo lo que queda de la vivienda
de Tatiana y su hija Verónica un
bombardeo aéreo destruyó su casa y otras
muchas de este barrio al norte Charly
Hill
no sabemos qué hacer no queremos
marcharnos queremos empezar a
reconstruir nuestra vivienda pero no
tenemos suficiente dinero
Tatiana es una de las pocas afortunadas
que han contado refugio para el próximo
invierno vive en un alejamiento para
desplazados internos que cuenta con el
apoyo de unicef y otras organizaciones
humanitaria
ha llegado el frío y hemos empezado
nuestro programa para la preparación del
Invierno significa que necesitaremos más
generadores para calefacciones
calentadores y otros aparatos eléctricos
van a llegar más desplazados mucha gente
está viviendo en casas bombardeadas que
no van a ser funcionales en invierno
después de ocho meses de guerra cerca de
800.000 hogares Siguen sin electricidad
Tatiana y Elena así como miles de
familias ucranianas han decidido
quedarse y enfrentar un invierno que
será más duro de lo normal
El parlamento Turco adoptó hace unas
semanas una ley muy criticada que
castiga con hasta tres años de cárcel a
quien se ha acusado de difundir
información falsa o engañosa debatidos
desde principios de octubre los 40
artículos del texto oficialmente llamado
ley de prensa fueron objetos de
numerosas enmiendas presentadas en vano
por la oposición que la denunció como
ley de censura los usuarios de las redes
sociales parecen estar en la mira del
gobierno como informan nuestras
corresponsales ludovic de hussein asad
en Estambul
casualmente estas organizaciones
internacionales habían acudido a Turquía
para debatir la nueva ley de
desinformación se aprobó el día antes de
su conferencia de prensa gurcanos turban
trabaja para el centro europeo para la
libertad de prensa y medios de
comunicación y Lleva años preocupado por
la restricción de la libertad de
expresión en Turquía tenemos que esta
ley como otras anteriores sea objeto de
abuso y se convierta en una herramienta
más para acosar a los periodistas y a
las voces críticas
la mayoría de los observadores
consideran que este texto dará un marco
legal a las prácticas que ya están en
marcha en Turquía extendiéndolas a las
redes sociales
el mundo digital el mundo en línea ha
sido relativamente libre es el lugar
donde los periodistas o el público han
sido más libres para expresarse Así que
Obviamente el propósito de esta ley es
aplicar más control en este último
espacio
a partir de ahora las redes sociales
tendrán que denunciar y entregar los
datos personales de los usuarios
acusados de difundir noticias falsas
Ibrahim de 25 años tiene más de un
millón de seguidores en todas sus redes
en cuanto se anunció la votación el
joven streamer que ya fue detenido hace
unos meses por un tuit lanzó una
petición en el sitio web change ya ves
que aquí estoy tratando de explicar lo
que esta ley hará en el futuro la gente
todavía no se da cuenta de lo que le
costará no solo los periodistas sino
también los ciudadanos de a pie ya no
podrán compartir lo que quieran en las
redes sociales recibo muchos mensajes la
gente me pregunta si sus antiguas
publicaciones se ven afectadas pero
dudan ahora borran sus antiguas
publicaciones según la nueva ley la
presidencia presentará al público un
boletín sobre desinformación y noticias
falsas cada lunes en 2022 reporteros Sin
fronteras clasificó a Turquía en el
puesto 149 de 180 países en su
clasificación Mundial de la libertad de
prensa en España más de 4.000 personas
entre las cuales 1800 son menores viven
sin electricidad Desde hace dos años a
unos pocos kilómetros del centro de
Madrid los vecinos de la Cañada real
llevan décadas reclamando una
legalización de las conexiones
eléctricas ni la pandemia de Kobe 19 ni
la peor Nevada en décadas hicieron que
se cumple el compromiso alcanzado en
2017 de mantener los servicios básicos
hasta que se encuentra una solución para
este barrio construido de manera ilegal
en los años 70 aquí el informe de
nuestra corresponsal Marina Colorado
Esta es mi casa
podés pasar
es un día atípico en la vida de Gladys
hoy si tenemos luz pero normalmente el
día que no tenemos luz Esto está oscuras
su voz normalmente tranquila y amable se
quiebra al describir la situación que
están viviendo no sé a veces a mí me da
ganas de llorar porque me siento
impotente
tú te levantas a las 3 de la mañana tus
hijos ha estado oscuras ahí durmiendo
el ser humano no
así llevan dos años más de 4.000
personas que viven en los sectores 5 y 6
de Cañada real galiana a 14 km del
centro de Madrid una antigua vía de paso
de ganado que fue ocupada poco a poco
hasta convertirse en una zona con más de
7.000 personas lo que algunos llaman
asentamiento irregular es para los
vecinos su barrio
Rosario con 82 años vive aquí desde los
Por ejemplo que he hecho que ahorrado en
mi vida Yo tengo uno duro del banco
entre comillas y todo lo que ahorraba
para la casa para la casa mis hermanos
Pedro Navarrete era el comisionado del
ayuntamiento de Madrid para la cañada
real Cuando en 2017 se firmó el pacto
que garantizaba unos servicios básicos
hasta encontrar una solución de Real ojo
o de regularización definitiva desde el
cambio de mando En la alcaldía en 2019
se está incumpliendo
cortándole la luz cortándoles el
suministro de agua haciendo todo lo que
sea posible para hacerle la vida
imposible Y que mañana acepten cualquier
tipo de realojo por muy sangrante que
sea para familias que tienen aquí su
arraigo la descalifica la situación de
chantaje emocional pero asegura que ella
no se irá de su hogar Seguiremos
luchando por nuestro barrio por nuestras
casas por nuestro por el futuro de
nuestros hijos más que todo un futuro en
el que la luz también sea un derecho
para la cañada real
como preparación para la copa mundial
femenina de la FIFA la selección
argentina ha estrenado una nueva
camiseta morada color que pretende
representar la igualdad de género en
Argentina como en muchos otros países
latinoamericanos el deporte sigue
impregnado de sexismo y para muchas
mujeres argentinas hacerse un hueco en
el campo es una lucha constante veamos
este informe de los nuevos manel Nicolás
flom y Anka olea en Argentina
cuando practican patear un balón
regatean y pasan hasta perfeccionar cada
movimiento estas jóvenes no están
simplemente jugando al fútbol están
luchando contra los estereotipos de
género porque aquí en la villa 31 La
Barriada más antigua de Buenos Aires el
campo de fútbol ha sido durante mucho
tiempo un mundo de hombres cuando era
chiquita o sea los varones no te dejaban
jugar porque los hombres eran muy
machistas y no no dejaban que las
mujeres jugarán el deporte el fútbol
para mí no tiene género ya que todos
somos capaces no pero a veces al decirte
cosas o al no compartir la cancha o
sacarte la pelota no no puede jugar al
fútbol Cómo estás hacer que el fútbol
sea accesible para todos es la misión de
Mónica Santos desde hace 15 años esta
antigua jugadora de fútbol lucha para
que este campo situado en el corazón de
un barrio desfavorecido se utilice para
la práctica de las mujeres dos veces por
semana para ella ocupar este espacio es
un primer paso para abrir más puertas a
las mujeres
los cambios empiezan ahí y no a partir
de recuperar una autoestima a partir de
percibir un cuerpo como fuerte en contra
de lo que nos dijeron históricamente No
que no podés ser agresiva que tenés que
hacer sumisa pensar nada más que tu vida
focalizada hacia la maternidad el fútbol
nos ayudó a nosotras un montón a
desarmar esos prejuicios esos argumentos
constanza es la prueba viviente de que
la teoría de Santos funciona tras años
jugando en el campo constanza convirtió
su pasión en un trabajo
y ahora sí ahora con 31 años se gana la
vida como entrenadora de fútbol cambio
un montón de mi vida Me formó como
persona
me guió a romper patrones familiares y
hoy en día me siento libre tomo mis
decisiones propias a través del fútbol
algunas mujeres argentinas han
encontrado su vocación otras han
encontrado una comunidad una forma de
brillar como equipo
hasta aquí corresponsales de la semana
nuestro agradecimiento es acabe espacio
para la cultura por habernos cedido su
espacio para grabar Este programa siga
con más información en Francia 24 y
France 24.com